bonsoir et bienvenue sur dia gones à
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs avec ce soir de retour parmi
nous le grand maître international et
loire où l'ange d'abord bonsoir et loire
et l'écrivain maître international
légende française tout cas au moins
française du jeu d'échecs nicolas
giffard mon soir bonsoir
alors peut-être pour démarrer avant
d'engranger d'enclencher pardon sur les
sur les thèmes pour présenter cette
émission vous étiez absent notamment ces
dernières semaines puisque vous avez là
maintenant l'habitude de venir sur ses
émissions mais pour donc un événement
français assez important puisque c'était
quand même le la finale du championnat
de france par équipe avec de très très
grands joueurs
c'était la phase finale de la première
division où se jouait le titre de
champion de france c'est clichy qui a
gagné pour la septième fois un record
et puis il y avait aussi dans le bas du
classement une lutte féroce pour rester
en première division parce qu'il ya
quatre relégués sur ses équipes donc
c'est très difficile en fait quand on
est un peu juste de se maintenir et la
lutte était très chaude et mon club a
terminé 12e c'est à dire juste devant
les relégués donc on a échappé de peu à
la deuxième division que c'est le club
de drancy notre ainsi qui sauve sa peau
voilà et les pauvres qui descendent sont
strasbourg chaise 15 paris kaïs à paris
et avignon qui joueront l'année
prochaine en 2e 10 ont remplacés par
ceux qui montent de deuxième division
qui sont toulouse le chesnay mots et
bois-colombes
je vois quand tu suis montré en première
division l'année prochaine pour un
championnat encore très fort cette année
la moyenne générale des joueurs étaient
à 2350 lots
quand on sait qu'il ya neuf joueurs par
équipe voilà ça fait 9 x 16 1
ça fait vibrer sur 150 joueurs une
moyenne donc de 2350 ces normes
y'avait adams qui étaient là au dessus
si ce mondial on a commenté une partie
il ya deux semaines là il y avait quatre
chiew est vraiment du beau monde à
montpellier ce week-end alors honneur au
champion de france puisque et loire
roland je te fais partie de l'équipe de
clichy et donc tu gagnes le titre voyez
donc pour la énième fois d'ailleurs je
crois oui enfin le titre dont clichy a
commencé bien bien avant moi puisqu'on
en est à notre septième titre bon c'est
pas consécutifs il fait attention le
record des titres consécutifs a été
détenu par lyon qui a gagné 6 ans de
suite ce qui est quand même exceptionnel
donc nous on en est à notre septième
titre bon c'est vrai que ce championnat
c'est c'était vraiment d'un niveau très
relevé on avait une très belle équipe
avec donc huit grands maîtres plus la
meilleure joueuse féminine française qui
est qui et marianne n'est pas une halle
aux comptes
hier elle vient de se marier avec donc
jean olivier lecomte pour les pour l'un
peule à la presse à scandale donc sinon
on aligne donc lui grand maître donc
notamment lautié donc je vais au pied du
gentil darwin coeur du tournoi d'indian
qu'on a suivi sur wii
et donc ces migrants m donc
il y avait moi igor nataf jean-marc
degraeve qui est venu à l'émission aussi
et deux joueurs anglais markets day
network conquest donc qu'ils sont très
bien dans cette équipe c'est une équipe
totalement francophone tout le monde
parle français et je pense que c'est la
cohésion en fait vraiment la bonne
ambiance qui avait dans l'équipe qui
nous a permis un peu de nous de nous
dépasser
puisque nos adversaires monégasque était
en principe plus fort que nous oui sur
le papier il y avait il avait recruté de
très grands joueurs dans les dames ce
don adams adler piquette s'il ya
beaucoup de joueurs européens ils ont
profité un peu de l'arrêt bosman
donc il y avait une île avait une très
forte équipe mais je pense que c'est un
peu sur sur la particularité de ce
championnat qui est les échecs par
équipe c'est sûr ça qu'on a fait la
différence avec une équipe bien soudée
qu'à monaco on a réussi à un peu à se
dépasser et donc à s'imposer devant
cette équipe de mercenaires mais très
très fort voilà donc victoire de clichy
et nicolas giffard grand si sofia
coppola et de l'est deux conclusions
qu'on peut amener à ce cette finale
championnat de france d'échecs par
équipes donc de neuf joueurs dont une
féminine aurait qu'alimente voilà pour
promouvoir les échecs rémunère en france
ça fait donc voilà donc bravo et bravo
aussi nicolas finalement bien de sauver
sa place ça fait toujours plaisir je
pense ça fait plaisir au club et puis
c'est aussi une dynamique
oui il faut dire que depuis que je joue
à drancy chaque année on est en jean et
on se maintient au dernier moment après
un suspense infernal web et donc ça me
permet après débouchés plusieurs du
champagne au milieu de tableau on a
beaucoup d'émotion alors qu'il ya des
équipes à l'argument qui viennent faire
la phase finale sans ambition ni frayeur
voilà donc là vous faites exprès à
chaque fois de vous mettre un tiers en
fait pas du tout exprès il se trouve que
c'est comme ça on démarre très mal le
championnat à la fin on arrive à se
rattraper in extremis d'accord ok donc
voilà bon pour ce donc ce championnat de
france par équipes avec cette victoire
donc 2
de clichy et loire aux langues de
nouveau champion de france champion de
france du nord déjà qui avait déjà été
championne de france junior et
individuelle n'a rien à voir ce qui n'a
rien à voir mais n'a pu en france par
équipes
voilà et sinon donc maintenant
l'actualité mondiale mais c'est surtout
semble-t-il eloi et nicolas il
semblerait que ce fameux match kasparov
à nantes dont on parle ce sa fin de
championnat du monde parallèle commence
à se préciser puisque son communiqué de
presse dont viennent de paraître
cosigné ou en tout cas appuyé par bessel
kok et donc serge grimaux nombre
d'affaires canadien je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de kiné québécois qui nous
regardent alors si vous avez des
informations sur ce serge grimaux au
canada n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
parce que nous ne connaissons pas en
fait on ne sait pas de qui il s'agit
autant qu'on aimait seule coque en fait
qui était le mécène un petit peu avec
une banque swiss je crois oui c'était le
fondateur de la gml comme mr
associations voilà avec master of fine
est déjà beau fait beaucoup de choses
dans les échecs c'est un mécène avant
tout est donc ce match aurait donc lieu
avec ces deux assurances la baisse et le
corps grand organisateur par le passé
est vraiment amoureux du jeu d'échecs et
des grands événements et chacun est donc
ce
ce temps d'affaires sage grimaud pour un
match avec 3 millions de dollars de prix
nicolas whisky et on en parlait tout à
l'heure ce qui est paradoxal c'est qu'en
général c'est un challenger qui a des
difficultés pour jouer contre le
champion du monde alors que là on
assiste à la recherche désespérée de
kasparov d'un challenger crédible et
alors ah non ne se fait prier à nantes
dit oui peut-être
c'est donc c'est une situation qu'on n'a
jamais vu dans le monde des échecs d'un
tenant du titre du champion du monde qui
a du mal à trouver un challenger à son
goût alors bon ce qu'il faut bien
entendu répéter c'est que cette
situation est très préjudiciable pour
les échecs puisque le match qui va avoir
lieu n'est pas n'est pas concerné par
une fédération reconnue oui marié
kasparov à le jouer d'une façon privée
oui il n'y aura donc pas de valeur
sportive est à son comble alors je crois
c'est une team ait world championship je
crois oui
donc ce sera le dernier championnat il
en veut il veut dire que ce sera le
dernier match de championnat du monde du
siècle c'est mon quadeurs vous savez
qu'ils se trompent puisque l'an 2000 on
pourra encore jouer le dernier match du
siècle mais il aura évidemment aucune
caution officielle reconnue par tout le
monde donc pas vraiment de valeur
ça sera un match exhibition comme il en
a fait de temps en temps mais ça ne sera
pas un vrai championnat du monde puisque
même sa fédération la professionnelle
chez associations ou la suivante la wcc
on
une vie éphémère association c'est
peut-être dire beaucoup parce qu'il y
avait souvent 3 4 personnes 2 dans quoi
en fait c'est à dire les gens qu'ils
avaient crées médias vous disent pas de
au départ c'était un projet ambitieux
qui pouvait tenir la route mais il se
trouve que il ya eu le sponsor principal
qui est partie et ensuite un finalement
une délit lequel question déliquescence
de de cette fédération et que maintenant
kasparov ne joue indépendamment de toute
fédération sévère d'une façon sportive
non reconnu ce que ce qui aboutit à un
manque d'intérêt des médias et un manque
d'intérêt ou jeu d'échecs avec général
très préjudiciable pour tout le monde
des échecs je dirais forcément puisque
même les passionnés que nous sommes on
est un peu dubitatif quoi c'est vrai un
championnat on a deux personnes sans
éliminateur sans élimination
il ya aussi un autre thème et loi qu'on
peut développer c'est que va faire un an
parce que bon il s'est quand même pas
encore officiel disons que kasparov à
dire donne évidemment son accord puisque
c'est juste qu'ils veulent organiser sa
meute il l'argent est là
prêts à être investis sur ce championnat
du monde avec ses 3 millions $ de prix
2011 vainqueur et un million perdant
mais à nantes d'un problème puisque
entre temps il va y avoir donc tu parles
de fer avec un voile à las vegas
championnat du monde de la fédération
internationale avec un contrat qui
stipule les joueurs qui arrivent en
quarts de finale n'ont pas le droit de
jouer un championnat notre championnat
du monde
un autre match qui s'appellerait
championnat du monde des chefs oui tout
à fait c'est vrai que ça pose un
problème donc à la bande annonce d'une
grande intégrité ça tout le monde tout
le monde le sait c'est reconnu alors je
pense que s'ils s'engagent à jouer le
championnat du monde fis dé quoi qu'il
arrive ne jouera pas contre kasparov
à mon avis dans sa tête il ne peut pas
il n'envisage pas de jouer les deux
matches donc à mon avis il va
vraisemblablement ne pas jouer le
championnat du monde fis dès cette année
pour aller vers ce match ait kasparov
alors maintenant c'est vrai que cela
peut lui poser comme un problème puisque
ce match n'est pas légitime
la fidesz est quand même une institution
qui qui a fait ses preuves qui dure
depuis longtemps donc à nantes aurait
tout intérêt à rester la fidh et mais
peut-être que l'appât des dollars va le
vin peut le perturber
c'est un choix un choix difficile qu'il
a maintenant à faire parce que est-ce
qu'il va aller vers ce match illégitime
ou alors est-ce qu'il va rester dans la
fidh et avec des chances de gagner qui
sont vraiment minimes hommes apparemment
ça me rappelle avait une mine allemande
moi ça me rappelle le fameux match qui
était un peu sur le même système le
famas kasparov short qui a eu lieu ou
short après avoir perdu ce match donc il
y avait joué or la fidh et aussi comme
kasparov qui avait perdu le match
c'était fait
battre le marte le match avait été short
comme avait dit karpov il est vrai pas
été si facile que ça pour kasparov s'est
il avait mis un certain temps à prendre
l'aventage mais il avait quand même
gagné assez clairement au final oui au
final oui le score final a été assez
fortement faveur des grottes du coup
après derrière mon cas soir celui de
toute façon était hors la fille d mais
après short avait toutes les peines du
monde à réintégrer ab il avait été exclu
de la fidh et ainsi que kasparov par
campo madness avec mes quatre forfaits
moins d'une fin du coup voilà
effectivement fin mai - après des
difficultés parce qu'il a toujours sa
notoriété
bon c'est qu'il est toujours numéro 1
mondial lui short était arrivé à faire
donc à être crédible pour jouer ce match
là puisqu'il avait été en finale du
championnat du monde officiel en fait
c'était ce match officiel quoi si je
voudrais d'abord c'est ça c'était un
match qui devait avoir lieu sous l'égide
de la fidh et c'était la finale normal
des championnats du monde fis des ils
sont allés la jouer c'est une autre
bannière parce que la ville de londres
donné plus d'argent que la ville de
manchester pour ce match lorsque je
voulais faire un festin parallèle short
avec beaucoup de mal après puisqu'elle
était ce que leur fille dsk ne risque
pas en acceptant ce match comme kasparov
à moins de le gagner peut-être même s
ils le gagnent de se retrouver tout seul
la disgrâce de shorts avait duré un an
un an et demi et pas plus maintenant
short jouent tous les championnats du
monde fis des puisqu'on l'a vu à
groningen joué très bien il manquait de
se qualifier de peu pour jouer qu'on
trouve que karpov
oui mais là ils essaient yumi nom qui
est champion qui est champion qui est
préservée fils et la fille des îles a
pas l'air de vouloir s'amuser trop non
mais enfin les promesses qui fait son
assez alléchante on a envie qui à las
vegas ça marche pas personnellement je
souhaite que las vegas soit un tournoi
comme groningen avait été mais avec en
plus les paillettes le strass les médias
donc un champion du monde spectaculaire
sur le jeu comme l'avait été à groningen
mais avec en plus donc
un suivi médiatique si las vegas march
bien que de las vegas or un champion du
monde on va dire je ne sais pas un nom
shirov et bien le match de kasparov
trois mois plus tard sera largement
d'évaluer du point de vue sportif
on sait que kasparov ses meilleurs
joueurs du monde bien sûr mais son match
là contre shirov sera sans doute négligé
par les médias commerciaux un vrai match
effectivement comme tu le dis ça risque
de donc de porter ombrage aux matchs
kasparov a dans la course à domicile
championnat du monde marchait bien mais
d'un autre côté s'il ya un an et
kasparov décide d'aller jouer à côté
aussi ça peut porter un beau championnat
du monde et jouer contre les normes sont
pas seuls puisque las vegas sera avant
le match de castres
oui mais sans les deux meilleurs joueurs
du monde bien sûr mais bien suffisant
imaginons en coupe du monde de football
un dressing d'allemagne bien sûr mais y
aura en perspective sans doute le l'idée
d'avoir le gagnant à las vegas qui plus
tard jeu pourra lancer un défi à
kasparov donc au rythme en sortir plus
d'inscrits
non non non bien sûr c'est très mauvais
comme situation mais comment résoudre la
crise actuelle je ne vois pas d'autre
moyen qu'une réunification sert le
vainqueur de ce gaz qui jouera ensuite
contre kasparov pour le titre mondial de
la fide et moi je voyais comme casper ne
voudra toujours pas il va vouloir
castorama toujours pas peut-être que
avec un match en partie avec mettons une
douzaine une quinzaine de parties un
match en longueur comme il l'avait
toujours fait à ce moment-là il
accepterait peut-être je ne sais pas oui
l'imposant certaines conditions
peut-être mais je pense qu'il est
conscient lui même d'ailleurs il a
reconnu récemment dans une interview
qu'il avait fait une faute en sortant de
la fidh et en 93 il l'a dit
textuellement j'ai fait une faute
ancré dans la pca en sortant de la fidh
et peut-être qu'il va accepter l'idée
d'affronter le vainqueur de las vegas
moi c'est ce que j'espère oui mais
peut-être la veille le vainqueur le
week-end ne pourra pas puisque dans le
contrat des joueurs
oui mais peut-être que la fille d et
kasparov trouveront un agrément un
accord ambitieux
il faut venir négocier je veux quand
même un risque pour ce champion du monde
fidesz a serait que un joueur inconnu
gagne le tournoi ce qui est tout à fait
possible avec ceux avec ce système il
sera pas un joueur sans talent ni sans
intérêt ensuite pour le suivre dans son
match contre kas par d'autres manières
le vainqueur mais maintenant de même
tout le monde est massacrée par kasparov
actuellement il ya aura aucun suspense
de toute façon donc enfin l' avantage
canada sur les autres participants de ce
championnat au fidesz et qu'il a déjà
joué un match comme kasparov
il a déjà joué 24 parties comme kasparov
un match on y là il a réussi plus ou
moins à tenir quand même sur la première
moitié du match
donc là il va sans doute essayer de
s'améliorer essayer de gommer un peu ses
faiblesses et donc cette expérience peut
donner un joueur comme un nombre des
possibilités qu'ont kasparov
alors que si c'est un des joueurs comme
par exemple fidelaire qui que qui n'est
pas très connu qui a dit doit être
numéro 12 mondiale peut très bien
remporter ce tournoi il est très fort en
système coupe
alors après spider gagne le championnat
du monde fidh et ça n'a plus aucun sens
pour la fidh et ça discrédite
complètement savez cet ancien de
principe c'est le principe même du conte
bande de fous qui a eu des surprises
aussi l'avenir on ne peut pas on peut
pas être sûr d'avoir le joueur favori
qui gagne mais cette fois ci des matchs
par élimination aussi donc on peut avoir
ce videur qui gagne je pense qu'ici il
gagne s'il faut pas oublier que s'ils
gagnent il va sûrement battre les autres
soeurs qui va battre à nantes il va
votre chronique et donc qu'il aura il va
gagner sa notoriété en gagnant les
matches
oui enfin le par exemple regardons jours
à munich n'avait pas joué à nom n'avait
pas joué il y avait beaucoup de joueurs
qui quand même avait refusé de jouer
sera venu à nantes avait joué à
groningen fait ce qu'il veut
bien que rami qui avait refusé à cause
de la nouvelle formule de jeu rapide et
le fait non surtout le fait que karpov
étaient parachutés directement en finale
du championnat du monde il avait refusé
cette idée et mais en fait personne ne
toute manière actuellement ne peut
inquiéter kasparov alors là la question
d'avoir un challenger à normes plus fort
capturez meneur comme je vis de leurs
n'est pas très importante ce qui est
important c'est que kasparov accepte un
jour ou l'autre de réintégrer la fidh et
d'affronter le mans alors réfugié mais
on avait la possibilité si on ne peut
pas accepter les autres comme kasparov
et le gagner oui il ya une petite chance
bien sûr on pourrait résoudre les
problèmes parce qu'un homme d après
capable de dire je suis maigre chance
est minime c'est actuellement kasparov
est beaucoup plus fort qu'à demande
alors peut-être ça vaut pas 3 millions $
dont ils ont trouvé le parrainage donc
on va pas s'en plaindre ainsi ils ont
trouvé un paria j'avais effectivement
annonce représente quand même quelqu'un
du tiers-monde quelqu'un derrière lequel
beaucoup de supporters peuvent
s'identifier enfin il peut donner un
engouement comme il l'a fait déjà bien
et puis c'est un homme et un en europe
de l'est aussi on va dire parce que oui
c'est ça se passe qui c'est un intérêt
et ça donne un peu d'exotisme au match
oui pis pour les échecs ça peut être
renouveau oui il est certain que quand
on avait joué en 95 contre kasparov les
médias s'étaient
beaucoup intéressé à lui parce qu'il
venait de nulle part un joueur indien
qui arrive aux championnats du monde en
finale
l'échec est pas prévisible c'est vrai ça
c'est pas possible pour eux pour les
médias jédir bien sûr mais d'ailleurs
traditionnelle et cialis des échecs
j'avais vu un an dans 88 allions jouer
un open jamais j'aurais pu deviner qui
deviendrait le numéro deux mondial
donc voilà bon mais on va clore cette
date m donc tout ça semble se préciser
donc faut dire que les échéances
approchent et que bon mais peut-être
aussi c'est sous la pression de ce
championnat du monde fidea las vegas oui
le casse parents se dépêchent aussi mais
je crois que kasparov est en manque de
reconnaissance de deux gîtes imité en
quelques sortes c'est difficile tout
seul entraîner mais il tente
désespérément de créer une fois avec
l'espagnol giron nouvelle fédération et
puis après ils essayent de rappeler ses
anciens amis mais c'est le coq etc
c'est assez tragique de voir ça et des
donc un champion du monde qui cherche
désespérément à challenger la nature
voudrait que ce soit le contraire
rappeler que kasparov lors de ses deux
derniers tournois étaient vraiment
impérial
ah oui alors qu'il était quand même en
perte de vitesse assez nette donc là
c'est vrai que le match devient plus
d'actualité à mon avis c'est à dire que
s'il est un peu relancé la sa
crédibilité mais de très belle façon oui
bien sûr on sait qu'il est le plus fort
ça c'est clair pourquoi si on avait le
moindre doute
en décembre je crois que quand on est là
nous serons là février plus bon donc
voilà bon on va suivre ça de près
évidemment et puis on aura j'espère des
nouvelles
définitive cette fois mais bon ça a
l'air très bien parti ce match on en
aurait donné un un corner il semblerait
mais bon à confirmer
on suivra ça encore une fois toute
l'année va être calé sur ces fameux
championnat du monde possible ou alors
la partie d'aujourd'hui c'est lié au
mémorial capable en calant nicolas tu
peux en parler parce que j'avais parlé
de toi sur les deux dernières émissions
dans les deux cas personne kg parler de
tuer les spécialistes de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs en france ouais je sais pas
vraiment non plus un historien propres
avec ce n'est pas un historien mais tu
tu as maintenant que lens harnes la
lecture de l'histoire des échecs mais
m'a toujours beaucoup plu et j'aime
transmettre donc c'est cette passion qui
m'a habité en lisant l'histoire d'egypte
aux autres mais je suis pas un historien
à proprement parler c'est à dire que je
passe pas mon temps à la bibliothèque
nationale a compulsé les anciens livres
ou les registres ou capablanca saurait
passer dans telle ville à telle date non
c'est non mais je lis les livres des
anciens tournois et je regarde avec
grand intérêt les anciennes parties
c'est vrai alors la semaine dernière
justement avait commenté la fameuse
partie capablanca marshall et donc qui
était la naissance moins médiatique en
tout cas d'une gambie marshall à
l'époque en 1918 et donc à la havane
actuellement a lieu un tournoi en
mémoire de ce grand champion cubain donc
le seul championne du monde cubaine
ailleurs d'échec
je peux presque renouvelé je pense parce
que c'est vrai que c'était quand même
c'est assez curieux de voir d'ailleurs
c'était un des rares exemples avec
l'oeuvre d'un petit pays qui fait mais
c'est dû à anthony monde d'échecs c'est
dû à la précocité de capable lancaster
qui il son père lui a appris à jouer
quasiment bébé et donc il ya une photo
célèbre où on voit
il a quatre ans on voit sur les genoux
de son père pousser une pièce à 4 ans
donc c'est vraiment des grosses joues de
bébés enfin c'est honnête je connais
cette photo et bien non je l'avalé suis
pas très histoire l'histoire du jeu
c'est plutôt dans l'actualité mais le
mur est capable encore expérimenté et la
technique et la technique tout à fait
oui je crois
ce numéro est capable en cas c'est un
très fort pour moi je pense que je
croise même le plus grand tournoi en
amérique latine tout simplement je crois
que la nouvelle enseigne à padoue il ya
d'étonnant en argentine ou non sont
assez fort mais mes choix qui arrivent
sont pas traditionnels wissant pas
qu'ils sont pas révélés mais et qui
arrive pas à ce niveau là quand même
parce qu'on a très très grand joueur qui
est sans doute no ken back gros et on y
jouer là bas est allé jouer je crois à
buenos aires on a eu des très très beau
tourner stéphane les mémorials d'âge
d'or oui mais qui en outre n'ont plus
aujourd'hui dont ils n'ont plus lieu
aujourd'hui mais avec vraiment naïf si
cher fischer aussi avait joué la barre
yaris à l'offre c'était vraiment des
joueurs extrêmement fort
enfin c'est vrai que là c'est une
tradition la même heure est capable en
cas tous les ans c'est c'est vrai que
c'est un très fort tournoi qui dure et
qui perdure donc grande tradition et
chicken à cuba et oui et puis qui a été
développée aussi avec la le lien entre
cuba et l'urss pendant longtemps les
liens économiques étaient très forts les
échanges culturels aussi et donc il y
avait beaucoup de joueurs d'échecs
soviétique qui allaient à cuba entraîner
les joueurs cubain et donc voilà
pourquoi oui niveau 1 tuba et fort oui
ça explique ces vrais faux billets
évidemment le lien qui m'a lassé
convenir soviétique donc mais on va voir
une partie en fait du vainqueur de l'an
dernier puisque dans le tournoi démarre
aujourd'hui donc on n'a pas encore
aujourd'hui avec le soleil en plus donc
les parties doivent être en train de se
jouer derrière pour la première ronde
soleil le temps que le soleil arrive le
mans
donc on a une partie du vainqueur de
l'année dernière donc robert hue
venerque entre anthony maïs troyen de
joueurs peut-être et l'ouest que tu peux
nous présenter le connais bien il ya une
histoire fabuleuse sur une aire que tu
connais sans doute nicolas il a dû être
en finale des candidats contre smith
l'ofs
quand on corse né à canton smith 9
réalité l'égalité le tirage au sort là
c'est ça l'égalité après ils essaient de
se départager avec de nouvelles parties
encore égalité et donc il faut faire un
tirage au sort à la roulette
alors vous dire je sens à la roulette en
finale des candidats alors donc je sais
plus quelle couleur choisir nerfs il a
dû prendre le rouge ou noir ben ali
c'est le zéro qui est sorti wen a en
fait eu le maire n'a pas voulu assister
à cette mascarade il a dit allez donc il
n'a pas assisté au tirage au sort à la
cérémonie avec la roulette et il y avait
seulement spin off qui a choisi rouge et
au début c'est effectivement donc il a
choisi rouge et puis c'est le zéro qui
est sortie qui n'est ni rouge ni noir et
puis ensuite smith tough a choisi la
couleur qui est sorti j'imagine donc les
états d'être le meneur dans la revue
tout stressé parce qu'il est très très
nerveux comme je vois de moins c'est un
des joueurs les plus cultivés il est
expert en papyrus également un papyrus
et papyrus égyptiens un expert mondial
reconnu des traductions riz les
linguistes
oui il a vraiment alors travaille
vraiment énormément sa nervosité a été
illustré aussi par le fait qu'il a
abandonné un match en plein en cours en
fait contre corse neu
il a fait une gaffe énorme et il s'est
fait placer une fourchette d'un cavalier
de kornoi qui faisait échec au roi et à
la tour vraiment un un coup et ça c'est
d'la complètement anéanti il est parti
il a abandonné le match c'était la demi
finale des candidats alors que le match
était pas fine quarts de finale des
candidats que je dise pas de bêtises
1980 oui l'année où swiss life est
arrivé en finale comme kasparov annoncé
c'était 83 c'était donc ça dépend à 80
le match kasparov smith l'ofs
non c'était en 83 vie en dansant et en
lituanie encore longtemps pour moi je te
fais confiance aux veys et le match en
question entre hugues nerfs et corneille
c'était avant le champion du monde 1981
de merano c'était donc en 1981 est
d'accord donc quand mes yeux ouverts
c'est pour dire qu à venir est arrivé
candidats aux championnats du monde il
était donc on a à peu près numéro 5 ou 6
mondial pendant de longues années
pendant là le début des années 80 et la
fin des années 70 ça c'est ça qui est
aussi fabuleuse les échecs ce qu'on
trouve des gamins de 6 ans ou sept ans
et puis oui parce que lunaire maintenant
à 52 ou 53 ans donc et on a des joueurs
comme cornouaille aussi qui soixante
huit ans 68 ans qui est toujours dans
les 20 meilleurs joueurs du monde quoi c
est là où il est en tête on n'a pas dit
mais il ya un tournant ce moment je
pensais en allemagne en hollande à
quatre joueurs il est en tête devant
saddler et judith pas
on dénombre riou la chinoise et un
quatrième joueur dont j'ai oublié j'ai
vu ça aussi corsa et d incroyablement
performante parce qu'il a gagné au
dernier classement 30 points elo à 68
ans il fait encore des progrès alors
voyons cette partie donc robert venir on
n'a pas parlé de 20 par an anthony maïs
et un anglais je crois qui est fantasque
il me semble qu'il a joué une partie
contre karpov un jour le coup curieux
après un 4 à 6 il a gagné me semble oui
c'est en suède c'était ça le joueur un
peu fantasque mais tout à fait autre 10
miles mais c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs anglais il a été en équipe
nationale anglaise pendant des années il
l'est encore d'ailleurs là aux dernières
olympiades je crois qu'il y était et il
est sans doute encore tout à fait donc
c'est vraiment un joueur très très fort
entre ni miles il est trés il joue très
très bien les tournois open c'est sa
spécialité il s'est qualifié je crois ce
qui est non il s'est pas qualifié il
était si la caisse initial il a fait 50%
au jeu semi-rapide enfin au démarrage le
départage voilà il a fait juste juste la
moyenne avec je crois que c'est le seul
joueur à avoir fait neuf nuls donc aussi
présents à las vegas je sais pas s'ils
auront bien revenir lui est qualifié
ozone avec les allemands je crois qu'il
s'est pas qualifié macally films ont
fait en tout cas il a été déjà donc aux
finalistes est candidat oui finalistes
oui moi je vous fais confiance de ne
s'aiment pas d'autres voilà donc robert
une mère contrainte on image rien cette
partie robert eau minérale est allé
blanc donc mémorial capablanca en 1998
donc l'an dernier le mieux reste de
cette année démarre en aujourd'hui on
n'a pas encore de partie à voir donc
voilà c'est parti donc très loin
et s'ils ont démarré voilà si on peut
mettre la partie sur la vidéo je vous
rappelle que pour suivre cette partie
vous pouvez sur la page de droite donc
de l'émission cliquer sur le petit
bouton il écrit joué vous rentrez sur un
applet java qui vous permet de suivre la
partie en même temps que nous nous
annonçons les coûts donc vous pouvez
vous repérer par rapport à la suite la
suite des coups dans donc dans cette
applet java vous avez aussi la
possibilité de télécharger un logiciel
et la partie pour la partie sur un
logiciel différent si vous avez des
problèmes par exemple avec cette applet
java pour télécharger ce logiciel vous
cliquez sur la partie émissions et vous
avez un logiciel soit pour pc soit pour
mac vous l'installer sur votre
ordinateur
et ensuite vous téléchargez la partie
qui est indiqué dans la une de
l'émission voilà apprécié des
indications techniques
voyons comment robert une ère démarre sa
partie contre 28 mars l or donc il joue
un des quatre donc pas de scinder coups
normaux
sur quoi miles ou cavalli et six
cavaliers f3
tout ça c'est très normal les donc
chacun des deux joueurs pour le centre 1
c'est la base de l'ouverture aux échecs
et l' attaque du centre rapide donc de
tony miles et une ouverture qui est
assez donc caractérisé par ce coup que
vous voyez là c'est cette c5
ils attaquent directement le pion des
quatre donc proposé un échange d'un pion
qui est donc un petit peu sur l'ale
l'option c'est vous voyez contre un pion
qui est plus centrale le pion des dons
globalement cet échange on peut dire
favoriserait le légèrement les noirs
s'ils avaient lieu c'est dire s'il est
noir venait à jouer c'est prend des
quatre ils se retrouveraient avec deux
pions au centre l'un sur ses 2 colonnes
qu on appelle des colonnes centrale
contre un seul ce qui est un tout petit
plus ça on va dire
plus un dixième de pions pour parler
comme les ordinateurs
donc c'est minimum mais bien entendu
donc tout ça c'est très connu une aire
ne permet pas cet échange et avance ses
pions
donc vous voyez qui si ils jouent des
quatre des cinq donc il prend de
l'espace c'est à dire que là il s'avance
il va dans le camp ennemi
et il place un fort pions un fort un
pion avancé examen avant postes voilà
qui fait petit de gêner les noirs
notamment par exemple ce cadre il est du
coup ne peut plus sortir sur cette caste
c6 donc c'est un pion qui va gêner un
petit peu les white mon avis donc ici on
arrive dans des structures qu'on appelle
structure de benoni ou structures du
dragon également on peut appeler ça
comme ça
ou pire que ça a beaucoup beaucoup de
noms c'est ça dépend ça va dépendre des
profits quand ça va dépendre des coûts
suivants tout à fait mais normalement
les noirs jde 6 suivi de g6 fou g7
voyez le fou là sera sur une belle
diagonale et des percées d'options là
donc ça c'est un développement normal de
la part des noirs mais tony lines s'est
d'ailleurs qu'elle depuis en la
contrôlant les cases noires ici donc
c'est plus en des 6-10 et ses cinq
contres en alain cazes des 4 et au 5 ici
ces deux cases avec un fonds placés sur
cette grande diagonale les cases noires
seraient bien verrouillé double contrôle
donne le contrôle dans la part des noirs
et donc les blancs auraient du mal à
lutter sur ces 15 mois voilà donc ça
c'est ça serait une idée tout à fait
normal
côté donc du côté noir mais tony malsain
à une idée un peu et qu'il a déjà
expérimenté donc qu'il joue ici dès le
troisième coup il joue quelque chose de
surprenant il avance un pion à l'ale je
vous parle à cette baie 5 voilà on ne
lutte pas tout de suite pour la 137
c'est ça dont on va dire ils abandonnent
complètement le centre et joue secoue un
peu un peu surprenant il option est en
prison vous voyez ce option v5 n'est
défendue par personne il est pas encore
attaqué mais enfin et c'est bizarre en
plus un principe très simple que que la
majorité des gens connaissent dans
l'ouverture
il faut sortir ces pièces faut sortir sa
pièce alors tu dis il n'est pas
effectivement on peut dire les deux
pions ne sont pas attaqués mais celui-ci
en fait est susceptible d'être défendus
rapidement par ce plan oui alors que
celui ci
bon mais peut aussi défendu par
l'entreprise oui il peut être attaqué
par ce coup a2 a4 qui est thématique
dans ce genre d'opposition dire que
besbes un jouet b5 c'est un peu trop tôt
ça fait partie en général du plan noir
vous voyez que donc dans la structure
qu'on avait défini avec geci c'est fou
g7
ça suppose toutes les pièces noires sont
dirigés par ici donc ça suppose une
expansion après des pions les noirs vont
avant sélection par là donc là tony mal
ça avance avant un peu avant l'heure
c'est à dire qu'ils disent l'oubli un
peu de sortir ces pièces là pour
directement commencé à prendre l'espace
de ce côté-là de l'échiquier alors c'est
un petit peu rapide à mon avis c'est
prématuré probablement et donc l'art
bergner va devoir attaquer très vite ses
pions un peu voilà ma fille voilà le but
pour les bleus c'est l'attaqué ses pions
à dire que mon faible
le dernier coup de miles et
caractéristiques de son style il aime
les coups provoquant oui c'est ce qu'on
ait à leurs valeurs là d'un karpov
oui en laissant pas s'étonner quand on
voit ça de sa part voilà c'est son style
on va dire c'est son style un peu
fantasque est d'autant plus qu'il avait
déjà joué ça contre garry kasparov
donc nicolas tu me disais que ce match
avait eu lieu dans les années 80 au
milieu des années 80 au milieu d'eux les
matchs d'entraînement de kasparov à
l'époque avant d'affronter karpov en
championnat du monde là en 1984 fin 84
s'était entraîné contre hugues nerfs
contre anderson ou s'il avait fait un
match à belgrade et contre miles mais
contre mal c'était peut-être pour un
match suivant contre karpov
c'est un peu bidon car hélas à miles
avait dit j'ai été écrasé par le monster
wizards à nice le monstre au milieu qui
voyait souvent fatigué joliment d'ivoire
et tous ces kasparov maîtriser
complètement tout l'échiquier
ratez rien comme des yeux de grosses
mouches
il avait déjà employé déjà employé en
fait cette ouverture contre garry
kasparov et avait subi une défaite
express miniature de garry kasparov ce
genre d'ouverture ne marche pas quand
tout le monde alors il a choisi une aire
pour jouer ça un début un peu
excentrique parce que tout le monde
connaît la préparation légendaire de
rodez rugby nerfs qui a fait des
ouvrages danalyse énorme donc aussi bien
pour l'analyse de parti que pour
l'ouverture luminaire est vraiment un
analyste
c'est très clair donc tony mal c'est un
peu par ce coup et c'est de le
surprendre de sortir un peu des sentiers
battus et joue un coup un peu
excentrique dès le début alors voyant ce
que comment robert guignard et ces deux
dates de réfuter un petit peu cette
conception voilà il y aurait alors ici
il joue faux j'ai 5
vous voyez il a sorti son foulard et se
propose donc de prendre ce cavalier qui
va détériorer la structure de pions
noirs point baignoire est obligé de
reprendre soit avec ce pion la soie avec
ce option là se trouverait avec ce qu'on
appelle des pions double et donc vous
allez voir d'options un là et un là qui
sont donc une faiblesse sur le long
terme et tony miles s'en fout l'animal
si vous foncez vite 17
alors oui on peut se demander ce temps
vous thématiques ouen coup on cale on
peut passer à cette position c'est à
dire bon mais effectivement il m'attaque
lecavalier ici peu qui pourrait être
dite aurions aimé structure options
pourrait peut-être jouer le cavalier ici
sur cette case ici et qui permettrait
l'attaqué aussi le fou le fond blanc
donc en fait tu proposes au quatrième
coup des noirs de jouer qui avait dit m
600 e 4 ce qui est un bon coup c'est
considéré par la théorie comme très
intéressant donc là le fou devrait
battre en retraite puisque aucun intérêt
d'échanger la kabylie contre un fou si
on n'a pas détériorer la structuration
donc on partirait sans doute en f4
maintenant je crois sur cas valeo 4 le
coup j'avais vu une partie ces dames
détroit et oui alors justement je sens
que c'est après x 4 avant garde on
enlève à vous et on vous donne des 3
après c'est l'inconvénient de cavaliers
aux quatre c'est que cette dame d un
viande et trois attaquants et le
cavalier est tombé 5
harvey d'accord et créant quelques
problèmes côté noir il attaque il me
semblait qu'on rapatrier le fou avant
alors peut-être que totalement chassé un
état chaotique cavaliers ou 4 est un
coup très intéressant je voulais
signaler c'est
les plusieurs suppositions enfin
possibilité choisi encore un coup dirait
secondaire oui enfin il faut dire que
kb24 n'est pas non plus très naturel
puisque on bouge deux fois la même pièce
dans l'ouverture ce qui ne fait pas
partie des principes des principes de
base donc ici tony ma liste décide de
développer une nouvelle pièce en
permettant donc à une ère de jouer 5 fu
précise qu'il joue entre maïs
reproduction eux alors voilà donc ici
structure de pions affaibli il a deux
groupes d'options un groupe ici est un
groupe de ce côté là oui la tentation il
obtint la paire de fou voilà l année de
fou puisque les blancs ont donné leur
fouet mais par contre cette option aussi
sans son petit peu gênant pour une heure
parce qu'ils sont difficiles à bouger
faut d'abord bouger le premier puis
après le second donc pas d'autant
mobilité copiant ici qu'ils peuvent
choisir de pousser soit l'un sur l'autre
donc c'est le désavantage d'être
renouvelé oui oui tout à fait c'est en
plus ça permet la casse devant au
général a tendance à être à fait me
voilà alors ici on va avoir quelque
chose de très important de robert hughes
nerfs quand on a des cavaliers contre
des fous il faut toujours chercher une
case une case une case d'appui pour ses
cavaliers il faut chercher comment dire
une encre fait qu'on pourrait appeler
une encre il faut souscrire une case
forte pour mettre ses cavaliers alors
comment va-t-il faire ici il joue ses 4
alors qu'elle est l'idée de ce coup
l'idée de ces quatre c'est d'échanger
ses deux pions c -b et obtenir la casse
et 4 pour le cavalier alors c'est à dire
que une fois que l'option b 5 n'existera
plus vous voyez que comme les blancs est
un pion en d5 la casse ces caps ne
pourra plus être attaqué par un pion
noirs desseins qui aura plus de clients
sur la colonne d ici le pian glas
empêche tout cuir noir de six pouces de
6 posté donc sept cas sur une très bonne
case pour un cavalier
voilà donc ici plusieurs réponses sont
possibles pour tony miles
il peut jouer éventuellement b4 à ce
moment là le pion va bloquer la case
naturel du cavalier ou alors il peut
jouer à 6 il a joué dans la partie donc
sur b4 l'inconvénient majeur c'est que
vous voyez qui aurait plus de pression
sur les pions blancs le pion des cinq
seraient défendus et la structure de
pions blancs les enfin disons que les
blancs le champ libre par l'as
l'expansion noirs seraient stoppés
simplement j'ai l'impression que ça
ici et ce fou serait très belle pour
aller vivre à la sortir puisqu'ils
seraient bloqués soit parce pions soit
parce qu'il était le meilleur ou quand
même peut-être b4 était peut-être b4
était préférable comparé à cette
ouverture de ligne comme vous allez le
voir donc
tony bates a joué à six donc là l'idée
c'est que avec ce coup c'est bon si les
plantes elles prennent évidemment le
pion peut reprendre contrôle ont
toujours cette caste c4 et sa garde la
souplesse de dire je peux encore
peut-être du riz plus tarder qu'à tout
prendre ici [ __ ] on va vers une
certaine souplesse à la salle est ce
qu'on appelle la tension entre les trois
pions en règle générale essayez toujours
garder l'attention quand vous pouvez
c'est à dire s'il a peu si votre
adversaire ne peut rien provoquer c'est
que votre position est meilleur disons
votre position de pions et meilleur si
c'est vous qui pouvez provoquer des
choses alors voyons ce que fait une aire
donc ils occupent carrément le centre
maintenant et le coût de 4 logique le
cupide consolide son impulsion son
centre des 5 et permet maintenant foot
de sortir pour se développer tous
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs il crée une menace si
stéphane puisque vous voyez qu avec le
fou qui sort il a créé une pression de
plus sur le point d 5
car maintenant le pion attaque le pion
et en cas de reprise se souviendra
simplement reprendre là donc ça crée une
menace
en plus d'être un coup très naturel qui
prend le centre et qui permet le
développement des pièces alors donc
maintenant on a planté le décor on va
voir maintenant comment donc vos rides
tony miles ne lâche pas la case c4 il
continue à défendre bay 5-1 il craque
pas il joue toujours pas b4 jude
investissent défendant encore une fois
sans tomber 5 peut-être qu'il aurait
c'était peut-être encore le dernier
moment pour crassier le problème le
problème quand même un risque ou c'est
que effectivement il garde attention ici
mais ils n'augmentent pas il augmente
par ailleurs qu'il faudrait pouvoir
placer par le foot plutôt ici pour créer
de plus en plus de tensions sur ce point
peut-être pour arriver à l'échangé de
points alors que la bon mais cette dame
même peut-être la menace et nord c'est
peut-être de prendre quand même ici
puisque la dame pourrait prendre le pion
b2 c'est peut-être une des idées tony
maïs mais je pense que dans cette
position les noirs ont plus de soucis à
terminer leur développement
qu'elle commence à essayer de
d'aller gratter on allait prendre des
pions un peu un peu olé olé c'est à dire
c'est ça ça prend un temps après ça
prend un deuxième temps pour aller
prendre ce pion là en attendant qu'est
ce qu'on voit c'est que le roi est
encore au centre qui est assez important
alors voyons et la ulnaire donc très
calme joue cavalier d2 évitons donc la
bonne à ce que tu avais dit stéphane
hains puisque maintenant après dépensé 4
éventuellement on reprend du cavalier
qui des fonctions b2 qui en plus attaque
la dame donc là des princes et 4 une
échec total de la stratégie noir puisque
les blancs auraient réussi à mettre
leurs cavaliers sur la casse ces quatre
en gagnant du temps donc là c'est
inadmissible il est impossible pour
tenir acte prononcé quatre et jude et
6,1 coûts de développement vous voyez il
essaie lui aussi de sortir ces pièces
s'il veut sortir son cavalier en 17 puis
11,5 essayer de maximiser ses pièces
toujours dans les positions il faut
essayer de visualiser où vous voulez
mettre chaque pièce donc ici en
l'occurrence le cavalier vite on veut le
mettre en å 5 donc le shom le chemin le
plus court s'est jouée dès 6 ans et
toujours avec l'idée de mobiliser
rapidement le plus de pièces possibles
pour avoir une force de frappe la plus
forte possible
et toutes nos pièces reste sur sa case
de départ elle n'a pas d'actions il faut
donner de l'énergie aux pièces tous à
orléans les mettant vers le centre ici
la case aux saintes au sein qui était
vraiment toute tracée pour ce cavalier
noms qui jouent des 6es la hublais un
point b 5
vous voyez donc on en est au neuvième
bout des blancs il joue ses preuves et 5
alors on comprend pas très bien c'est
une concession après la reprise de toni
miles apprend b5
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les blancs
n'ont pas la casser 4 les noirs ont
ouvert la colonne à et peuvent
maintenant comme tu l'avais dit stéphane
renforcer un peu leurs positions avec x
6 donc pourquoi est il joué ça la
réponse vient immédiatement après il
faut dire b on joue à quatre d'accord
donc là la menace des blancs c'est de
prendre ici ambitionne tout simplement
par exemple vous prend avec l'échec
oui et
avec sa dégaine de pions aussi région
suivie de garde la case ces quatre là il
y dix huit mois c'est qu'après les
change ici mais la cascade sayed
appartient aux cavaliers et ici c'est
déjà l'échec de la stratégie des noirs
puisque il est impossible de garder la
case c4 donc là les blonds avec leurs
deux cavaliers vont réussir à
s'implanter sur ces enfin un cavani va
s'implanter là alors que tony valls n'a
pas réussi à faire parler son fou f8
qu'on aurait pu envisager très très bien
sur cette diagonale là avec une très
belle action
donc là c'est un peu dans le temps que
ibn rdr a bien géré son son ouverture
donc maintenant il craque mais un peu
tard vu que la case c4 a été libéré par
la rue de nerfs il pouvait pas vraiment
faire autrement parce que la prise du
pion à 1,4 donc faut rappeler peut-être
au 10e coup un dixième plus pour lier
pour les noirs donc là nicolas tu dis
qu'il n'avait pas trop le choix
oui il peut pas par exemple je vais
fouet à 6 c'est une variante a mentionné
alors si les noirs avaient joué 3 6 avec
l'idée de toujours contrôler cette caste
c4 est de protéger le pion par exemple
les pions prendre on prend le fou
contrôle a cassé quatre mais
effectivement il ya un petit ennui la
tour noire ne serais plus protégée
voilà donc faut imaginer c'est que fois
ci c'est effectivement avec l'idée
toujours en elle l'idée c'est de
contrôler cette case donc qui comprend
blanc fou prend et le fou contrôlent
toujours la casse et cartes mais du coup
la tour noire n'est plus protégé et une
fois que ceux qui ont de l'or a disparu
évidemment tout reprend tour avec une
tombe
et puis l'autre tentative des noirs qui
al'air plausible c'est de faire pions
prend pions elle avait chuté qui en
prend pied en pour au moins gagné un
pion c'est ça la gélatine attaqué le
pion par la dame noire va attaquer
l'option b 2 et les blancs peuvent
répondre cavaliers en c4 avec une donc
si tu apprends pillant les blancs jouer
toute la vallée c4est
nomination forte alors c'est pas évident
cette vente ne m'a pas l'air clair après
pions prend pions cavaliers c4 on
jouerait dame b 4 échecs l'autre cavalli
reviendrai mais à ce moment là on a
défendu notre tueur à 4
la dame occupe une position assez
intéressante de laquelle on ne peut pas
la chasse et et les blancs non pas de
menaces dans cette position nicole bas
ils vont alors qu'elle est en ils vont
sortir leur pièce ranquet et puis plus
tard encore été la dame noire j'imagine
mais c'est impossible de chasser la dame
noire paraît bien là disons que la
position de pièces noires me ressemble à
une forteresse en fait alors qu'est ce
qui calmerait play jouer alors qu'est ce
qu'il ya mais je pense que sur b3 car
ils avaient peur d'une ouverture de
lignes supplémentaires simplement tout
reprend 1,4 sacrifions b2 marine et noir
pourraient prendre un pied en mai 2 mai
à rouiba la réplique est tout de suite à
ce refus tf1 tout de suite ce n'est pas
une variante évidente
ouais donc d'accord on peut la
mentionner que parce qu'elle est
importante l'accord comprend un capteur
points à 4 sur dame prend b2 on joue
tout reprend tour feront tour hélas la
dame d un vient on à quatre avec échec
voyez échec au roi cavaliers et en même
temps le x 8 est en crise une fois
l'état voilà donc c'est une fois ça
finit par une fourchette et l'autre
solution c'est de se dire on empêche les
plans de prendre un pion prend tout
reprend les noirs eux mêmes prennent
d'abord mais du coup la dame prend le
pion avec échec avec et après le
cavalier peut sauter tranquillement sur
la case b 4 4 sur deux réfuté par d'un
programme et avec une très bonne
position blanche oui tout à fait donc
ici je pense qu'ils avaient peur
d'ouvrir les lignes il voulait calmer le
jeu à ce moment là à quoi penser toni
mal si pensez à laisser le moins de
pièces possibles arrivées en jeu il
voulait un peu fermé fermer cette aile
de l'échiquier voyant que le combat
était déjà perdu alors voyons ce qui se
passe là donc il a joué 10 b4 essayant
de calmer la situation
alors voilà c'est maintenant l'heure de
sortir un surprenant non bien joué de la
part de
une ère ils se précipitent pas sur quel
s et 4 d'abord ils ramènent encore une
pièce il met son fou en b 5 avec échec
l'idée c'est plus fous est sorti on
gagne en deux temps puisque les noirs
doivent répondre à l'échec et après on
me le calice et 4 avec un fou mieux
placé que s'il était derrière le
cavalier ce qui me rappelle un principe
donc nicolas tu me dira peut-être de qui
sait quand on a vu un bon coup faut
toujours rechercher un meilleur et
beaucoup de joueurs se seraient
précipités sur cannes et ses 4 mai
foulée 5 est meilleure et donc c'est le
deuxième coup qui vient à l'esprit en
fait dans cette position où elle et
kingfisher l'avait cité dans son livre
mais ce n'était pas de lui c'était
effectivement je m'en fous je crois
cette caresse mais je suis pas sûr je
sais pas bon enfin ce principe est passé
à la postérité
quand on voit un bon coup chercher un
meilleur il y en a toujours un donc la
très logique cavaliers 17
donc on ne craint pas d'être des rockets
puisque de toute façon on n'avait pas le
choix c'était soit bouger le roi sous
chaque aïd et sandero christ seigneur si
les blancs prennent le cavalier les
noirs sont obligés de reprendre du roi
du coup le rock n'est plus possible
puisque le roi bouge mais voilà c'est un
lieu simple on a perdu le droit de rock
et donc qui avait laissé quatre
maintenant donc elles n'auront pas peur
de ça il est blanc d'ailleurs s'y
précipitent pas il préfère cloud et la
pièce oui oui tout à fait et alors là ce
qu'on voit c'est que les blancs fait
domine toutes les cases blanches ils ont
pris toutes les cases blanches ce qui
est un peu là la faiblesse en fait côté
noir ils ont leur [ __ ] cases noires
ils ont tous leurs pions sur case noire
dont qui contrôle parfaitement les cases
noires même ce cavalier qui en 17
il est sur une case blanche dont qui
contrôlent que des cases noires voyez
que les noirs contrôler toutes les cases
noires mais la table on chiale bien sûr
case blanche contre les gaz mmm est dans
leur camp
ah oui un avantage des stars ayant cédé
contre les cathares dans son cas c'est
pas tellement gênant pour l'adversaire
non il n'ya que en fait y'a que le pion
b4 c'est un pion s'est s'inquiété aux
méthodes contrôle des cases un camp des
bleus en fait
mais alors que on a le pion blanc qui
contrôle la case aussi sa place et 6 le
fou qui contrôlent des cases adverse le
pire ont aussi est un cavalier contrôle
maintenant mais b6 et des six ce qui
fait beaucoup de casse dans le carnet
noir qui sont prises donc les noirs sont
obligés de reculer par rapport à ça et
c'est ce qu'on voit tout de suite
puisque la dernière en inde doit reculer
dans la bosse à nanning donc les noirs
jouent au douzième coup d'essai cette
alors un petit bilan dans cette position
stéphane oui
j'aime bien les bilans passés ça
clarifie les idées donc est ce que les
blancs peuvent jouer sur le long terme
ton avis dans cette position risque
éventuellement que les noirs se déplie
ou alors est-ce que c'est à dire le long
terme et changer des pièces arriver en
finale quoi tu veux dire simplement
qu'on le maître les tours au centre
essayer d'améliorer la position des
pièces mais je sais pas trop je ils ont
l'air de bien contrôler de bien
contrôler lafarge des pions noirs là
puisqu'ils pèsent ils peuvent pas trop
avancé
bon il faut pas oublier que les noirs
ont la paire de fou si ce fou arrive à
s'activer par exemple ainsi les noirs
jouent beaucoup j'ai six maîtres se
leurrent sous un g7
peut-être avec le coup et f5 après le
fou va avoir de l'air et les noirs vont
pouvoir faire jouer leur père de fou
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire que sur
le long terme la paire de fou risque de
s'exprimer éventuellement cirque on peut
très bien envisager que si les noirs
jouer quatre coups de suite
mettons g6 fou g7 petit rock ont des
clauses cavaliers cavaliers entre 5 et
éventuellement après remettre ce fou
lancé vite pour je préparais f5
ils auraient une position plus que
correct puisque ce fou g7 dominerait
complètement l'échiquier tronc humain
peut visuel voir dans le carnet noir
voilà certains le carnet blanc
exactement ça serait dans le camp des
blancs donc et alors que les pieds les
pièces blanches quant à elles sont
toutes à leur maximum déjà pratiquement
avec les blancs appart petit rock
après ils vont plus trop trouvé coûts
pour améliorer leurs positions donc les
blancs doivent baisser de com de trouver
quelque chose encore le travail mené par
exemple empêcher les noirs de rock et
sans feu chez les noirs de rock et voilà
c'est jouer pour les initiatives tout
simplement ils ont sorti plus de pièces
plus vite donc la lumière joue pour
l'initiative il comprend très bien
défendu cette position et donc ils ne
rendent pas ils jouent à cinq dans les
carpates temps par l'europe c'est
finalement le roc serait une perte de
temps c'est vrai que ça permettrait au
noir par exemple de jouer le couffo
cette même source un jauger 6 est à même
de faire rapidement le rock qui
permettrait des clous et ce cavalier qui
pour l'instant ne peut pas bouger
oui tout à fait donc à 5 et un coût très
important ici pourquoi donc menace
directe le cavalier vient en b6
d''achat' ont protégé par le pion donc
l'idée de coûts et protéger ses quatre
des six cavaliers donc pour y gagner
voilà donc le cavalier en cloud et ne
peut pas prendre la tour est attaqué et
le cavalier est attaqué ça serait donc
impossible de défendre tous a donc déjà
première menace directe assez
désagréable apparaît on voit bien que ce
fou et emprise mais ne peut pas être
attaquée est pas protégé et tu veux dire
on n'est pas protégé par un prisme n'est
pas protégé alors violée à tour à paris
il faut bouger la tour y aurait
également fois ci ce qui serait réfuter
de manière différente donc c'est pas
forcément une proposition très
intéressante
ça aurait une proposition de
simplification en fait on peut jouer fou
prend 17 et sur dame prend aux apprentis
cavaliers b6 maintenant avec fourchette
tour dames ou alors on peut jouer
cavalier b6 tout de suite et surtout
plombés 5 prendre cette tour on habite
donc fois ci ce qui serait une
lucio disons de com on peut appeler ça
de liquidation et changer quelques
pièces pour alléger un peu la tension
n'est pas bon donc comme tu dis nicolas
il faut bouger la tour prévenir la
menace en fait donc il joue 13 tours à 7
donc avec l'idée c'est que une fois que
ce fou à jouer à la fois le fait la tour
du cou à une action pour protéger aussi
cette pièce et surtout la tour se dérobe
l attaque du cavalier la taille la tour
se dérobe de la taille du cavalier blanc
mais c'est surtout ça donc ici cavaliers
b6 donc là là alors suite à ce coup car
les v6 donc protégé par le pion à 5
il ya une menace directe c'est fou prend
17 avec échec et la dame cécile dame
reprend évidemment le cavalier d'une
dame donc ça ne gagnerais le cavalier
oui donc là le câble est en prise par
deux pièces qui ne sont pas échangeables
ou attaquable dans l'immédiat donc il
faut faire une coupe de défense donc le
dit cool unico dans cette position
c'était fou s'est vite au 14ème goût
donc on va maintenant sur une prise
éminemment le fou pour reprendre ce qui
est beaucoup plus ça je peux perdre la
dame évidemment et laure donc là on se
retrouve encore moi-même même situation
que la dernière fois
c'est que les noirs encore si on leur
donne deux coups et je vous fous aux 7es
petit rock suivi par cavani pro b 6 on
va échanger les pièces si on arrive à
ceux des clous et de ce clou âge donc
une fois de plus subvenir doit doit
faire des plans d'action rapide dans
cette position et il trouve ce coup
assez assez impressionnant très jolie un
quinze qui a validé quatre c'est la
seule pièce qui peut venir en jeu voilà
arrive à trouver une case c'est
extraordinaire cette position vous voyez
ici toutes les pièces blanches semble
semble participer à l'action sauf cette
tour là mais qui est un peu longue à
mettre en jeu
ce cavalier là on se demandait comment
ils pouvaient participer il est bloqué
par l'option f6 il peut pas venir là ou
là mais alors il vient quand même là se
mettant aux prises
oui les emprises donc avec le pire en
noir qui peut faire pire on prend des 4
on a l'impression que c'est une gaffe on
dirait pas alors là c'est un amateur des
rires c'est une gaffe
j'ai gagné une pièce un amateur du
racing a donc sûrement je suppose mais
c'est très beau parce que ça a l'air a
défendu nos échecs tous les coups water
défendu et qui sont effectués quand même
ouais ils sont beaux oui c'est vrai mais
moi tout de suite moi je me dis bon mais
je le prends et après je vois donc c'est
un show prend des quatre îles et il a
anticipé bien entendu il ya tour c'est
un voyez attaque la dame alors on ne
peut pas interposés le cavalier ce qu'on
aurait envie de faire puisque il est
cloué toujours la foulée 5 vient de
répondre le roi donc la dame doit bouger
mais dont on peut considérer dame 17 et
la tour viendrait prendre le fou on
s'est vite avec des chèques et protégé
parle toujours parce qu'à valider sujet
sur lequel il dessine sa vraie présence
cavalli mais les deux pièces blanches
sont très très forte ici le cas et b6 et
le fourbe et 5
vous voyez que vous pouvez essayer de
chercher dans cette position ces pièces
ne peuvent pas être déstabilisée elles
sont sur des positions tellement forte
qu'on ne peut même pas essayé de les
échanger
donc là qui est des 4 une fois qu'on
voit que la prise est impossible ça
devient très très dur pour les noirs
quand même parce que ce cas lié peut
envahir ans et six attaquants latour
attaquant la tour commença à réduire
bien le jeu le jeu noir dans ce moyen
d'action assez difficile pour tony miles
ce qui se passe alors tourbe et c'est
très bien voilà ça prévient la halle
attaques de la tour finalement c'est
très bien la taille de la tour et sert
donc il arrive à provoquer ce cookie et
france évite donc ça ne provoquait pas
avoué après tour 17
il n'y a pas de menace les noirs ne font
pas de menace encore dans cette position
enfin éventuellement ils peuvent le tour
tombé 6 oui si le liquide et voilà
donner à tout reprendre car à l'ipp
récupéra un pion au passage envoyé au
moins limites
enfin
liquidant la tension permettant de finir
le développement je vous faut c'est tes
petits rangs qu'après sans être embêté
par des pertes de matériel donc la robe
et revenir voit une suite forcé il joue
donc réponse est vite d'un procès 8 à 6
et voilà ce petit pion maintenant qu'il
devient un vrai poison ici la dame le
pion n'a plus besoin de soutien lequel
et b6 donc on avance ça me fait penser à
ce que disait bronstein dans son livre
zurich 53 en milieu de jeu quand vous
avez un pion passé il faut toujours
l'avancé comparer attention c'est pas du
tout pareil en finale ou en finale
l'option passé on a plutôt intérêt à le
garder en mania c'est la menace la manne
assez forte que l'exécution en milieu de
jeu le pion passé fait diversion c'est
ça la grosse nuance c'est qui fait
diversion c'est juste un pion après tout
quand il ya beaucoup de pièces étaient
des maths en perspective on envoie les
pions diversion panique que finalement
même si l'aja prend l'option ça sera pas
toujours grave puisqu'on aura réussi à
un peu désorganisé toutes les pièces
ainsi la tour de jouer suivant les
conseils connu depuis 1953
il envoie le pion à six voies la
tourasse est donc là l'idée pour les
noirs c'est de bloquer tout simplement
là maintenant le pire ne peut plus
avancer
si la tour avait joué un v8 en or encore
sûrement poussé le bien on aurait poussé
psion est tout à fait donc ici cabanis
et 6 alors vous allez voir un petit un
thème géométriques assez joli mais je le
mentionnais une fois qu'il sera terminé
donc a laissé six attaques la tour donc
là il n'y a pas trop le choix
tours à la joute aura 8 ce qui lui
paraît logique à cette maintenant alors
je rappeler le coup mené au cou du 11/19
pour ceux qui suivraient qui arrive est
maintenant sur l'émission sur la plaine
java donc on est au coût du héros 19 des
blancs le cou à cette qui maintenant
étouffe les noirs je dirais puisque
menace cavaliers en b vite semble-t-il à
voilà nicolas vue avait une possibilité
très forte secours ce quoi c'est d'abord
immobilisé noir puisque la tour du cou
n'a plus de gaz peut plus bouger
elle est fixée sur cette can et nicolas
dit qu'il ya une menace forte puisque le
coup car elle est payée vite ici
attaquerez lecavalier 17 qui ne peut pas
bouger ils ne pourraient pas prendre le
car il y à cause du fou en b 5 qui
ferait échec au roi donc ce cavalier
cloud et donc suite aux coups cavale et
v8 il semblerait que le cavaly 17 n'est
plus défendable il est attaqué par le
cavalier et le fou
ce cavalier protégé par le pion donc là
et noir sur une situation la perdante la
monnaie salaires imparable non saturés
18 et complètement imparable mais alors
il ya une autre menace peut être encore
plus forte
parce que vous voyez qu après qu aller
vite on peut envisager de donner la
qualité encore avec tourcoing bébittes
je comprends dame prend aucune position
devançant l'allemande perdante mais
peut-être encore jouable je pense que la
menace comme les noirs ne peuvent rien
faire du tout dans cette position c'est
tout et damas kat d'abord suivi qui
avaient vite après qu'il a ne gagnera
plus une qualité mais une tour entière
puisque après tout retombe et vite si on
prend damperon c'est parce qu'on est
déjà prêt à prendre ce cavalier en 17
mois là et on aura une grande avance
donc de toute façon ce qu'il faut voir
dans cette position c'est que les noires
n'ayant plus de coups tout simplement ne
peuvent plus sortir leurs pièces ne
peuvent plus rien faire
les blancs peuvent préparer avec assez
donné un assez bon timing
on peut noter d'ailleurs que l'idée ce
serait de jouer le roi pour sortir de ce
cavalier du souk l'orage mais
on ne peut pas puisque le cavalier
protège des seule case droit pourrait
jouer tout à fait et alors donc petite
variante sur fou aux 7
on jouerait cavaliers province est roi
prend est fou c'est 6 gagnant facilement
par exemple jeu il ya peut-être d'autres
donc ici désespoir un peu de tony my
eyes sont mis en échec
enfin il va se mettre en échec scolaire
le cavalier seul avec la découverte et
le cavalier un sortant en fait un joli
motif puisque les italiens soit un sur
un échec au roi c'est une part à la
menace qui avait classé le seul coup en
fait c'est par la dares le seul coup
qu'on arriverait était imparable mais
non ouais c'est pareil alors là donc à
vue vous allez voir une petite petite
manip sympa alors venez rejoue cavaliers
pro b 4 échecs donc échec par le fou ça
s'appelle donc un échec à la découverte
le cavalier libère le fou qui fait échec
au passage on gagne mcur ans déjà le roi
vendée vite et maintenant on revient
qu'elle et ses six échecs alors là elle
n'aideront c7 ça serait quand même ça
serait pas très joli mais je crois que
c'est ce qu'il va faire il sait ce qu'il
veut on peut dire qu'un aileron 8 7 ans
assis revient s'il revient ils peuvent
continuer
il peut faire encore comme dans la
partie on va voir d'ailleurs la décision
du menez are de gagner un pion libère
quand même le roi noir je sais pas est
ce qu'il n'y avait pas mieux que faire
cette capture de pions cavaliers pro b 4
échecs
il faut dire que les noirs mais malgré
le fait par exemple il pouvait pas jouer
tout rang à six attaques et le cavalier
c'est possible aussi on avait les
solutions pour gagner
de plus trop ce qu'on fait peut-être
l'idée aussi attention idée à mon avis
nicolas aussi c'est que le maintenant
exceptions mais quatre n'existe plus
beaucoup b4 va finir d'ouvrir je prends
la broye noir va finir d'ouvrir le jeu
près du roi noir et il va succomber
attaques des pièces puisque ce juana par
ok donc il est au centre
on a tout intérêt à ouvrir le jeu et le
couple de quatre maintenant est possible
grâce à la prise de ce pion donc je
crois que d'ailleurs on va voir voilà
relancé cette donc le roi essaie de
sortir de l'échec de dix cavaliers
hélas alors c'est joli ça ne se calment
ça c'est un jouet un coup car on a
l'impression qu'il faut continuer la
taxe mais non tout simplement unis
rejoue l'outil rock et là on voit que
anthony mal s'abandonne en fait ne
continuez pas la partie je pense que je
pense que cela on suivrait par le coupé
4 me semble que ça a l'air peut-être le
coup mais c'est à dire qu'on a besoin de
plus nos pièces sont toujours
indélogeable le roi noir
on se demande ce qu'ils font c'est 7 et
comme tu dit stéphane après b400 savez
comme erik haula le coutour à 6 aussi
parce que ça va lui ça va fixer
complètement les noirs ray tour à six
avec la perspective d' amener ensuite la
dame aura cinq ça mais rien aucune
perspective un pion de moins un pion un
set complètement indélogeable deux
pièces qui sont pataca puisqu'en plus
l'énorme occaz blanche ont fait
d'énormes parce que attendant les coudes
et blanc et répondre mais ils ont des
jeunes qui ont des mêmes leurs coûts d
attente sont pas nombreux même le
reconnaît c'est juste parce que par
exemple le fou peut pas sortir le
carrier le prendrais tout de suite là
tournoi besoins des problèmes insolubles
ils n'ont pas de coût simplement je
crois qu'ils sont aux 8 juin nicolas
nous rappelle ce que sait pas encore
tout à fait tousser consulting peut-être
il ya la tour noire à droite qui peut se
promener 2 h 8 ans g8 pour attendre ah
oui on pourrait on pourrait jouer tôt
j'ai tout de suite et je pense qu'un
plan des blancs ce serait de jouer par
exemple tout raciste qu'on utilisait
pour obliger peut-être la dame noire
aller sur une case pour prix soit figé
la défense peut-être et le coup
peut-être b4 et jouer je ne sais pas
d'âme ses deux tours c'est un pur masse
et des pièces sur cette colonne et le
double bang c'est la situation dans
laquelle le seul coût possible c'est je
passe mais voilà ces chèques on n'a pas
le droit donc
on est forcément obligé de faire un coup
perdant 1,28 pour les progressistes il
me semble qu'ils ont donné une
définition encore plus strictes aux
gangs
et puis ce sont deux exemples sont celle
dans laquelle chacun des deux camps
devraient dire je passe c'est en fait un
espèce de zone en grèce hyproc ou celui
qui a trait est obligé de en fait de
faire ainsi sa place et les couleurs ça
serait l'autre camp qui gagne rien voilà
si tu joues tu gagnes tu perds si ton
adversaire tu joues tu gagnes donc les
autres sont des termes de probléme liste
voilà bon en terme de produit c'est
encore plus donc je voulais enfin vous
c'est pas eu besoin de vraiment cette
position mais ça y ressemble fortement
c'est très rare les deux banques dans
les positions il ya encore beaucoup de
pièces comme celles ci n'ont en général
c'est dans les femmes parties où il
reste très peu de choses moi je suis
arrivé dans une fameuse partie vous le
savez là encore je vais encore partir
j'ai encore partie des digressions mais
une partie car pauvre kasparov et karpov
un moment donné avec toutes ces pièces
sur la première rangée et il n'y a plus
de coup je crois qu'il avait une
politique c'est pratiquement et du nord
est pratiquement une fête donc voilà sur
la voie la fin de cette partie on arrive
à la fin de notre émission ça va faire
une heure donc ce joli partie donc mais
morale capablanca 1998 donc cette année
un nouveau tournant avec de grands
joueurs tous les noms des joueurs cette
année et dont j'ai quelques problèmes
pour me connecter
tu problème un petit virus donc sans
ménager j'ai vu qu'il y avait avec 100
dans le siège genou il y en a bien un
qui est venu en france gagné le tournoi
gonfreville l'orcher dangereux termine
second à 8 secondes derrière miser sur
le visage il a dominé le tournoi il ya
aussi son compatriote kevin sprague est
alexandre grandmaître un grand maître
québécois est maintenant c'est le
meilleur joueur canadien devance prague
est je crois qu'au vélo il a dû doubler
ses parts guette et il ya aussi
évidemment des joueurs cubain il doit y
avoir des joueurs espagnols williams
hajem je pense j'ai vu des noms du style
saddler non mais si oui il me semble
aussi il me semble aussi alors je suis
plus bonjour sa fait un tournoi de
catégorie 16 quelque chose comme ça à
15,16 donc c'est pas mal coiffé un
moyenne lots plus de 2500 six ans
nicolas 2006 sort des médecins dans les
catégories sociales c'est plus de 1600
ou est très longue et c'était catégorie
tient cette moyenne est louable de métis
en avant voilà donc ce baisse mais moins
capable en cas donc comme en souvenir du
fameux championne du monde cubaine dont
on a parlé lors des deux dernières
émissions voilà qui démarre aujourd'hui
donc évidemment le suivra la semaine
prochaine sûrement dans deux semaines il
est possible aussi qu'il ya donc un
tournoi à sarajevo à sarajevo avec notre
argent
voilà mais à partir du 16 mai après la
semaine prochaine à royan à nous mais
voilà il y aura pas démissionner la
semaine prochaine puisqu'il ya donc il
est fait en france et canal web est
fermé il me semble vendredi prochain
voilà bien jouent donc je vous remercie
et loi je vous dis bon soir nicolas au
soir
donc la prochaine fois moi je vous dis
donc aussi au revoir et pour une
prochaine mission diagonale sur
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
à très bientôt
il
oui